casi en todo lo que hemos hecho hasta
ahorita en cálculo hemos usado límites a
ver dejar como por aquí límites hemos
usado límites para determinar derivadas
de funciones derivadas de funciones
de hecho la definición de derivada usa
la noción del límite es la pendiente
alrededor de un punto conforme tomamos
puntos más y más cercanos al punto en
cuestión vaya me tengo que decirte la
verdad porque ya lo hemos visto muchas
veces antes en este vídeo vamos a hacer
lo opuesto es decir vamos a usar
derivadas derivadas para encontrar
límites para encontrar límites ok
estos van a ser límites que caigan en
ciertas formas indeterminadas y con esto
de forma sin determinadas me refiero a
que al tomar el límite acabamos con algo
del estilo pues 12 0 entre 0 o bien algo
del estilo infinito entre infinito o
bien en los infinitos entre infinito o
vaya a cualquier cosa del estilo más
menos infinito entre más menos infinito
cualquiera de éstas es una forma
indeterminada vale ahora sí vamos a la
nueva herramienta para resolver este
tipo de límites usar
una cosa que se llama la regla del
hospital voy a poner aquí lo y tal
la regla de
el hospital en este vídeo lo que quiero
contarte es que dice la regla del
hospital y cómo se usa en realidad es
muy sencilla pero es una herramienta
súper poderosa incluso para competencias
de cálculo a veces te ponen límites que
acaban en una de estas formas de las de
acá y es casi seguro que quieren que
utilice es lo vital pero bueno tiene una
prueba muy difícil quizás en otro vídeo
la demuestre lo cual es un poco más la
toso pero ahorita nos limitaremos a las
aplicaciones que son bien directas
entonces lo que dice la regla del
hospital es lo siguiente dice son varias
hipótesis fíjate número uno lo voy a
poner todo muy abstracto y ahorita
cuando veamos algunos ejemplos va a
quedar más claro pero entonces dice que
si el límite de cuando x tiende a c de
fx es igual a cero
si es igual a 0
el límite de cuando x tiende a se deje
de x es igual a 0 también y otra cosa
más esta es otra hipótesis
además el límite de cuando x tiende a
ser de un cociente de f prima de x entre
g prima de x es igual a cierta constante
es decir existe y es igual a l
entonces si todas estas condiciones o
bien hipótesis se satisfacen en el caso
0 entre 0 si se satisfacen entonces
entonces podemos decir que el límite de
cuando x tiende a c de fx entre g de x
es igual también a l
vale entonces es igual a l esto de aquí
puede parecer un poco extraño pero bueno
ahorita voy a escribir los otros casos y
después vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
para que todo quede más claro va
entonces este de aquí es el primer caso
vale ahorita voy a hacer un ejemplo en
un ratito para fijar las ideas pero por
el momento vamos al caso número 2 cuando
el límite de cuando x tiende a c de fx
es igual a más menos infinito vale este
es el otro caso entonces estamos
pidiendo eso y luego pedimos también que
el límite de cuando x tiende a se deje
de x sea igual a más menos infinito y la
misma hipótesis de acá arriba o sea
también pedimos que y otra vez vamos a
poner algo en términos de una fracción
entonces el límite de cuando x tiende a
c df prima de x dividido entre g prima
de x existe y es igual a l entonces
podemos hacer la misma conclusión es más
como va a ser la misma misma conclusión
pues voy a copiarla y pegarla entonces
voy a seleccionar esto me voy a cada
edición copiar y luego edición pegar a
esta sale esto de aquí es la conclusión
que nos da la regla de lopito ok
entonces la situación típica para usar
el hospital es la siguiente
digamos vamos a caso de cero entre 0 nos
piden encontrar el límite de este
cociente para cuando x tiende a c pero
tenemos una f que se va hacer o cuándo x
tiende a c y una g que también se va a
hacer o cuando x tiene hace entonces si
estas dos se van a cero y nos
encontrar digamos el límite del cociente
lo que vamos a hacer es considerar el
límite del cociente de las derivadas y
vamos a calcular su límite de cuando x
tiende a c si ese límite existe y es
igual a l entonces el límite del
cociente normalito también existe y es
igual a l aquí abajo también pasa algo
parecido cuando tenemos infinito entre
menos infinito o menos infinito entre
finito o cualquier combinación vale de
infinitos entonces estás de acá son las
dos formas indeterminadas que vamos a
tratar va ahora si salgamos de la
abstracción y vayamos a un ejemplo para
que todo quede mejor explicado entonces
supongamos que queremos determinar vamos
a poner un ejemplo y lo voy a hacer con
otro color como morado entonces vamos a
buscar el límite de cuando x tiende a
cero de seno b x dividido entre x ok
entonces si simplemente vemos esto e
intentamos evaluar es este límite en x
igual a 0 verdad conforme nos acercamos
a 0 pues que es algo del estilo 0 entre
0 porque el seno de 0 es igual a 0 o
bien el límite de cuando x tiende a 0
x es igual a cero y pues del mismo modo
cuando aquí se va a cero pues aquí
también se va a cero verdad entonces
esta es la forma indeterminada ahora
esto de aquí la fx pues va a ser seno de
x efe de x y la gtx pues va a ser aquí
la gtx va a ser igual a x entonces aquí
le pongo cd x es igual a equis y fx es
igual a seno de x muy bien ahora observa
pues definitivamente ya sabemos que se
cumplen las primeras dos condiciones
verdad aquí se es igual a cero pero
cuando aquí se va a cero entonces seno
de x es cero esa es la primera hipótesis
y el modo similar pues que de aquí
también se va a hacer o cuando x se va 0
entonces tenemos la forma indeterminada
pues correspondiente pero vamos a ver
qué pasa con las derivadas vale vamos a
tomar el límite del cociente de las
derivadas
conforme x se va a 0 y vamos a ver qué
sucede vamos a ver si el límite del
cociente de las derivadas existe
entonces lo voy a hacer
pues digamos azul va entonces voy a
escribir las derivadas de las dos
funciones por aquí efe prima de x es
igual a 7 s de x f prima es la derivada
de seno es cosa de x eso ya lo hemos
visto varias veces verdad y sigue de x
es igual a x entonces que prima es súper
fácil verdad simplemente nos queda 1
entonces vamos a intentar encontrar el
límite del cociente de las derivadas el
límite de cuando x tiende a cero de f
prima de x entre g prima de x vale
entonces eso va a ser igual a
jose no de x / / / 1 bar y que sucede
con este límite el 1 europeo sobre 1 y
qué sucede con este límite cuando x se
va a cero pues conforme x se va a 0
coseno de x se va a 1 y entonces el
límite nos queda 1 pues aquí le voy a
poner dividido entre 1 voy a escribir el
resumen de esto acá a la derecha lo que
acabamos de ver es que el límite de
cuando x tiende a pues nuestra se vale 0
verdad entonces cuando extiende a 0 df
prima de x dividido entre g prima de x
es igual a 1 este límite existe y es
igual a 1 entonces ya satisfacemos todas
las hipótesis del caso 0 entre 0 cuando
x base fx es igual a 0 el límite de
cuando x tiende a ser eje de x también
es igual a 0 y el límite de cuando x
tiende a cero de f prima de x entre g
prima de x o sea que nos quedaba coseno
de x entre 1 ya vimos que es igual a 1
así pues todas estas tres condiciones o
bien estas tres hipótesis se cumplen y
las reglas del hospital nos permite
a esta conclusión entonces el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x
dividido entre x es igual a 1 es igual a
1 porque debe tomar el mismo valor que
el límite del cociente de las derivadas
de cuando x tiende a 0 este fue un
ejemplo de 0 entre 0 en los siguientes
vídeos vamos a ver ejemplos de las otras
formas indeterminadas para fijar todavía
más las ideas